como ahora vamos a hablar concretamente
de fútbol femenino para escuchar la las
palabras de una de las grandes de este
deporte de quién se trata de la
colombiana linda Caicedo la mejor sub-20
del mundo según la federación
internacional de historia y estadística
del fútbol quien hoy ofreció una
conferencia de prensa en la que dio
pocas pistas sobre Su futuro y es que
linda está a dos semanas de una fecha
crucial su cumpleaños número 18 con lo
que ya podrá oficialmente escuchar las
ofertas que le llegan tanto de Estados
Unidos como de Europa nuestra compañero
Luis Méndez conversó con Linda quien
compartió las expectativas sobre el
mundial de Australia Nueva Zelanda y
también sobre Su futuro profesional
Bueno realmente todas mis compañeras
estamos cargadas de expectativas
obviamente falta para poder llegar allá
de poder disputar el mundial ahora
Estamos en microciclo estamos en prueba
el profe viendo las jugadoras Que
obviamente quiere llevar para allá
entonces de ir afrontando cada rato con
con mucha humildad con mucha alegría y
logrando cosas importantes como equipo
Bueno realmente en cualquiera de los dos
es como ver también donde podía fluir mi
juego pero bueno analice bien siento yo
que los dos por ir adaptarme la mejor
manera como te digo ahora me quedase
esperar Yo también quisiera poder hacer
las cosas rápido pero bueno por tema de
edad y crecimiento uno no me deja